even in this weary world that we live in
dreams do come true yes dreams do indeed
come true ariana debose makes oscar's
history as the first afro latina and
first openly queer woman of color to win
an academy award for acting ariana won
in the best supporting actress category
for her role reviving the iconic anita
in steven spielberg's adaptation of west
side story after receiving a standing
ovation the actress delivered an
emotional and powerful acceptance speech
to the lgbtq plus community you see
a queer openly queer woman of color and
afro-latina who found her strength in
life through art and that's what i
believe we're here to celebrate
yeah
so to anybody who has ever questioned
your identity ever ever ever or find
your you find yourself living in the
gray spaces i promise you this
there is indeed a place for us
beautiful now in response to ariana
making history glad president and ceo
released an inspiring statement reading
ariana dubose is an immensely talented
actress and a tremendous advocate for
lgbtq people and people of color she not
only made history tonight as the first
queer woman of color to win an oscar but
she sent a beautiful and timely message
to lgbtq young people i hope lgbtq youth
around the world saw her win heard her
speak and recognize that they too should
dream big